so let's start this off today we're
going to talk about exploring c-sharp
ate the deep dive my name is David pine
you can follow me on twitter at david
pine 7 i hope that you do and if you do
please take pictures and tweet them at
my handle so that my wife knows i'm
actually here today you can follow my
blog at david pine dotnet where i blog
about all the things almost too much too
many things right i blog about c-sharp i
blog about angular typescript the the
idea of imposter syndrome i blog about
building magic mirrors for fun and all
those things right so check that out so
we're gonna start with a few notes from
microsoft a few things that you should
know about c-sharp 8 so most of the
features are implemented entirely in the
c-sharp compiler which is a huge
advantage but some of those features are
not available they actually require
dotnet standard 2.1 or dotnet core 3.0
and sorry but defaults interface
implementations that requires an
entirely new runtime so you'll need
dotnet core 3.0 for that and it won't
even be shipped as part of that
framework for point 8 so just a bit of
housekeeping about some of the features
so we're gonna start looking at async
streams and we're gonna cover some of
the the the types that were added and
kind of justify why some of these
features require changes under the
covers right so there are some new types
that we're added so we have a new system
dot I a sync disposable everyone should
be familiar with AI disposable now if
you're a.net developer just real quick
show of hands who's a.net developer
right obviously thank you for attending
my talk we have system dot I a sync
innumerable of T and I async enumerator
of team then we have ranges right so
they added system dot range and system
index and we'll get into more details
and what these actually
like encode itself but those are just
some of the new types that were added
and some of the reasoning why not
everything can be just magically there
from the compiler so since the default
interface methods I'm not able to show
you what those look like in code like
from the IDE Visual Studio itself I'm
gonna show you on slides instead so I
want you to imagine for a second that we
have an interface an eye data repository
of T and we have a simple create method
void returning that takes a T value and
obviously does something right as a
repository would do it would create that
persist it somewhere so now imagine that
we want to add a new API as it stands
today right prior to c-sharp eight what
would this do this would cause a problem
you'd probably lose friends in the
process because if you're adding things
to an interface you're potentially
breaking implementations that you know
implement that so we want to add a
create all given an array of T values so
what default interface methods is
proposing is the ability to in our
interface itself provide that default
methodology right we're actually we have
logic in here and you'll notice that
it's actually referring to create which
is something that's already on the
interface itself so this is going to be
kind of an opt-in thing where
implementers can override this by
providing their own implementation
that's kind of like magic right it's
pretty cool I also want to take a second
to talk about target type new
expressions so this is something else
with c-sharp eight that's going to be
very interesting and compelling so
imagine we have a point class we've got
a couple properties off of it x and y
and we have a constructor that's given
an x and y and then we have this
deconstruct now deconstruct
if you've been following along with
c-sharp c-sharp has become open-source
and the language itself the design team
allows anyone in the community to you
know provide proposals right pull
requests features things that they want
to do and you know it's an open dialogue
and they encourage that and I think
that's extremely powerful but some of
the things that they've been doing is
they've had point releases so if you've
been following along with C sharp like
c-sharp seven seven point one seven
point two seven point three they've
introduced the concept of tuples into
the system and with that tuples had this
magic method name called deconstruct so
on anything that's not a tuple you can
say public void deconstruct and you can
provide some outs parameters and as long
as it compiles right and you're
assigning to those out parameters you
can walk up to that instance and
deconstruct it as if it was a tuple
which is pretty amazing so what we can
do with this point class right it's not
a tuple in this point class we can say
to have an instance of it and
deconstruct it and have those x and y
values available to us another thing
that I added here has been in the end
net for a long time in c-sharp for a
long time and that's a public static
implicit operator so implicit operators
are pretty powerful again they've been
around for a very long time just real
quick show of hands who's used an
implicit operator a couple people you
will see why that's important in a
second but basically it allows us to
implicitly treat the tuple literal X&Y
as a new instance of a point right so
today we might write we might declare a
pointer a points equals this this new
array of points right what they're
proposing with target type new
expressions is since the type is known
from our declaration we can omit
the type itself right so we can say
simply new open friends close friends
and then X and why is that pretty cool
you guys think that would be like a nice
feature to have what's really
interesting is they've they're
introducing this with c-sharp babe but
with the implicit operator that I've
shown you if we were to take it a step
further we could say point array points
equals new point array and because of
the implicit operator in tuples we can
omit new and point altogether right so
we just literally have what looks like
tuple literals which is I think awesome
so we're gonna jump into Visual Studio
2019 we're gonna spend a lot of time in
here and this is going to be the bulk of
the talk and we're gonna work through
various c-sharp eight features and one
thing I want to preface this with is
that I'm fairly opinionated so and I'm
empathetic I'm by title a Technical
Evangelist but I empathize with
developers who are constrained to the
limitations of you know the bureaucracy
of enterprises or large teams and those
types of development environments where
you might have limitations with what it
you know you can use and things like
that so one thing I like to do is I like
to put this chip on my shoulder and say
these features are amazing right and
most people will come up here and tell
you that but there's always a but like
how does it apply to you what's
practical why do you want to use it what
are the actual advantages of it just cuz
it's new and shiny doesn't mean you
should be using it
so we're in Visual Studio 2019 I've got
a c-sharp eight project and to clarify a
bit I'm going to zoom in and show you
something that you may or may not be
aware of so if we right-click on the
project and we say properties and we
head over here to application and click
build in the properties tab if we go
down towards the bottom there's this
Advanced tab we click on that this
actually is where you can select the
various version of c-sharp that you want
to target right so this project can now
target c-sharp 8 beta so that's good
so this c-sharp 8 application is a
simple council app it's nothing to write
home about it's not super exciting we
are using John Skeets demo utility just
show our hands if you know who John
skeet is I assumed as much and what it
allows us to do is basically have
various main entry points in different
classes and it's a way to kind of
orchestrate demo code for c-sharp
council applications so let's start with
async streams so our async streams one
thing I like to do real quick is there's
a bunch of confusion in the community
right now about async streams in
particular they'll think of them as
being somewhat related to the idea that
reactive extensions offers with reactive
extensions
it's basically an implementation of the
observer and observable pattern right so
the key difference is with ienumerable
and i async enumerable is that those are
pole based right so we're pulling stuff
and processing them as quickly as we can
with the observer pattern and our X what
you have is like a subscription type of
pattern where things are being pushed to
you so you
bribe and provide like an on next as
like a callback some of the issues with
that are like the concept of back
pressure and how do you handle that
right since you're not necessarily the
consumer of that right you're being
pushed to and you have no control of how
many times you get pushed to whereas the
the opposite way of you know just
pulling it so so I want to show you that
we have a simple struct a statement that
has an ID in a description and we have
the ability to return them this way I
want to do a real quick review of the
concept of ienumerable so with
ienumerable there's a special keyword
that you can add to ienumerable
returning functions that is yield so
who's written iterators before who's
used the yield keyword okay this is
great
good a lot of times people don't raise
their hands so I like to cover that so
what this means is that this block of
code is going to be treated as an
iterator so it's deferred execution and
that means that it's not going to be
executed until this ienumerable is
materialized until we either call like
to array or to list or for each over
that collection right so one of the
general questions we'll ask is like if
error was true which I don't know why
we'd ever in production code have a true
situation where we're throwing like this
but bear with me if this was true and we
were to throw an exception here and I
was to call get statements what would
happen the correct answer is nothing
right you get your ienumerable back and
until you start to materialize it that
at that point in time that's when that
exception is actually thrown so that
could be way later on so we have an task
returning of ienumerable statements
right just demonstrating that and this
was pre c-sharp eight so you'd imagine
how now you know with the future of what
c-sharp is doing we wanted to you know
try to join these two worlds
with tasks tasks based parallel or sorry
task based asynchronous programming
allows us to represent the execution of
code right so we're basically saying
this is going to happen and it's gonna
it can happen asynchronously all right
so it's it offers up the potential for
suspended execution so now we're merging
these two concepts right we have these
new types so we look at ia sync
enumerable so we can get state
statements asynchronously and we're
gonna return ia sync enumerable so
that's allowing our our async methods to
also have the yield keyword in them so
this is basically joining the concept of
deferred execution with the potential
for suspended execution right so we have
a stopwatch here and we'll get
statements so the statements is an I I
think enumerable of statement we can
iterate over those notice that when we
iterate over them we're saying a wait
for each right so this syntax is
familiar but also new and then we're
just going to print out the elapsed time
for each of those statements so let's
run this real quick
and bump the size up on that real quick
also zero and then basically every
second will will pump out the evaluation
of those asynchronously awaited and
deferred execution all married so that's
that's basically async streams which is
pretty cool right so one thing that is
also very cool but also not cool and
that is nullable reference types and I
say it's not cool because to me when I
first heard the concept of nullable
reference types it was terrifying I
thought to myself what is the c-sharp
team smokin like what are they doing
like we know quite frankly what are they
doing why are they thinking of this as
an idea like what to me reference types
have always been nullable so to
explicitly state that no you know
reference types are not able it didn't
really compute with me I knew that
nullable was something that was
introduced around value types right
Struck's we could say we have a
questionable date time right with the
question mark and that made it nullable
but reference types that didn't really
make sense so what's the big advantage
here and one thing that we like to to do
is developers is talk about the notion
of the billion dollar mistake so show of
hands if you've heard of this concept
the billion dollar mistake and this is
coming from the inventor of null he says
it's the billion dollar mistake and as
a.net developer I will guarantee you
that you have had a null reference
exception at one point in time right
object reference not set to an instance
of an object to show of hands who is
dealt with that probably too often right
so what this feature is looking to do is
to help alleviate that problem it's
helping to alleviate that concern some
by having the power of our IDE light up
and start saying you know what you
didn't think of this case here you
should be more defensive in your coding
so in this specific example I have a
pound nullable so a compiler directive
and I'm gonna say enable we're gonna
look at how our IDE starts lighting up a
bit so we have a person class with first
name middle name and last name and we
have two constructors one of which which
is just taking the first and last name
so we know from the constructors itself
that we're not explicitly assigning to
the middle name and the IDE knows that
also so the ID is going to tell us that
we have a potential problem write a non
nullable property middle name is
uninitialized so what can we do right
what we can do is we can really express
our intent so we can say that middle
name the string here we can say middle
name is questionable right so how does
that change what our IDE might do in
terms of intellisense further down the
pipeline right so let's exemplify that
so we're gonna instantiate a person you
got Miguel and we have a function that
gets the length of the middle name of a
given person and this is coming from
c-sharp seven where they introduced
local functions so we're gonna get the
length of the middle name and here the
IDE is telling us more about that right
let's zoom in again and it says one
thing you'll notice is I say string who
likes to use string versus like var for
example who who likes bar I guess that's
a better question great imma bar
advocates i I prefer that because I'm
lazy right as developers I think we're
all lazy so far is less than saying like
dictionary of string of dictionary
because we have nested dictionaries for
some odd reason right so we have a
string here this is our middle name
we're saying it's a string middle name
equals
person middle name and one thing you'll
notice is that the middle name is
actually a questionable string right
it's a nullable string so we're
expressing our tent right we're telling
we're giving some hints that we are
explicitly stating that the middle name
can be null and should be treated as
such you know considering flow analysis
so we have this personal name and we're
saying okay this is not what we're
looking for so we'll use var instead so
that that concern goes away but now we
have middle name here and it says we
have a possible dereference of a null
reference right because we don't we
don't know for sure if that's not or not
so what what can we do well let's just
use the Elvis operator and then Cole
asked over to zero and now we've written
code defensively right so the the main
advantage here is that we're taking
something that's you know a class in
this case a person class with the
variance of a middle name and we're
explicitly stating that it can be null
and as such we should treat it that way
so wherever it's being used the compiler
can queue on that and say ah-ha
here's some suggestions right it's not
perfect and it's going to be very
earth-shattering I was reading a blog
post by John ski where he talks about
how this if you start turning this on
and all your solutions for example if
you start moving over to c-sharp bait
it's going to potentially have the same
effect or wow factor as async/await
did right it's gonna be massive it's
going to up heave the massive and it's
gonna be something that shouldn't be
taken lightly but the goal is to help
developers write more defensive code and
hopefully end up in a state where we're
not having the frustration of null
reference exceptions cool
all right so let's talk about pattern
matching there's a question you can do
the same thing with I mean so string is
a special case but yeah we would come to
me afterwards and we'll talk more about
that all right so we're going to talk
about pattern matching and some of the
enhancements with pattern matching
specifically so we have a public a new
rainbow and we're defining red orange
yellow green blue indigo and violet as
we'd expect from an enum we have an RGB
color class that holds a byte for the
red green and blue values so we're gonna
look at switch expressions so imagine
that we want to have a way to convert
the rainbow into the corresponding RGB
color so we have a switch on that you
know definite type right the Union value
and we will return the RGB color
instance right that's that's how we do
it today so with switch expressions one
of the things that we can do is now we
can let's say metaphorically speaking
we're gonna taste the rainbow things are
going to get better right so we have
that same rainbow color and we can
express this as notice how the syntax
has changed so rather than saying switch
open and close prints on that type we're
saying here's the type now we're going
to switch on it and our case labels are
a lot more terse so rather than saying
case and having you know our colons we
simply have the value right so rainbow
red is expressed as the new RGB color
right so it ends up being a lot more
terse less less verbose right more
expressive I think it's a lot less
boilerplate it's easier to read in my
opinion and then we've introduced the
notion of
which are special so this is basically
the the fall through of no no case was
matched so we're going to throw an
exception so now we have an address
class and we have some various
properties right we've gots the address
line one in line to a city estate postal
code the country and region so I wanted
to show you now property patterns and
what's really amazing about property
patterns so imagine that we want to
compute sales tax based on an address so
we have a sales price we're going to
express that also right so we can walk
up to the location and say switch on it
but now we can evaluate individual
properties on that instance as part of
our switch expressions right so we can
say location switch and then evaluate
what the state is so if the state is
Washington here's the sales tax right or
if it's Wisconsin but then also the city
is Milwaukee right we can treat that
differently and this is where
specificity comes in right same as all
the case labels that we've ever written
in switch statements before right the
order matters so if we're in Minnesota
we're just gonna say it's too much and
if we fall through we don't have
anything right pretty cool let's talk
about tuple patterns now to pool
patterns are just another way to express
our switch statements here with pattern
matching so we have a simple game of
rock-paper-scissors and the first and
second argument are either a rock or
paper right Rock Paper Scissors on any
of those options so we can switch and
say on this tuple itself right
evaluating this tuple what are the
various case labels that we would define
for them and those are expressed as such
right and we can just say that we're
going to return a string so we'll switch
on that tuple and if the first ones rock
rock obviously covers paper
right so we can say rock covers paper
paper went or is covered by paper rock
versus scissors paper vs. rock so on you
get the idea right and if we end up down
here we can just say tie if there ever
the same so let's talk about a little
bit more in depth here so we have a
shape and our shape defines a height and
a length as any good shape should it's
got the constructor right so we've got
our height and length and then we have
some subclasses we've got a circle that
defines a radius and the diameter and
the circumference and then we have a
rectangle that says it's a square if the
height and width are equivalent
right so otherwise it's still just
rectangle with its height and length so
we can pattern match on objects also
this was pre C sharp eight specifically
but still really cool to talk about how
we can use it in this context with
switch expressions so we can walk up to
a shape and get the various details from
it so we'll say shape switch and if it
is the type circle we have it inside
that expression right we have it as C so
in the scope of this case lay the case
labels like you know expression C is
available it's not only available but
it's of type circle so it has everything
hanging off of it that we'd expect which
is super cool we could say rectangle s
when s is a square right so we're saying
more explicitly that yeah it's a
rectangle but it's also a square so in
this instance we have a square we know
for sure that those height and length
are going to be equivalent in this
expression otherwise we can fall through
to a rectangle otherwise we can just say
discard it's an unknown shape and just
throw our hands up and walk away from it
right
so this was part of the initial slide
deck rice showed this point class so
let's kind of skip past that but I just
want you to remember that we do have a
point class right it's got x and y on it
and we can deconstruct it but then we
also define another email for quadrant
right so we have unknown
we've got origin quadrant 1 you know 2 3
4 right so just imagine that or you're
on a border so we have positional
patterns as well so we can say you know
take a point and say from that point we
can plot out a quadrant so we can say
Point switch and since we're able to
deconstruct this point into a tuple
literal we can have those as case labels
right so let me say that again since we
have a point instance and that point
object defines a deconstruct method that
outs both the x and y we can express
that point as a tuple literal so we have
a tuple literal and those can serve as
our case labels right so our case labels
are 0 and 0 and that's expressed as
quadrant dot origin right smack dab in
the middle or we can say var X Y when X
is greater than 0 and Y is greater than
0 then we're obviously up in Quadrant 1
right and so on and so forth and we can
just plot that out we can discard here
at the very bottom and say where unknown
there's a question so yeah the question
was what's the difference between 255
and 256 discarding here is so this so
the difference is that with the
statements above they are more explicit
and if we fall through to a situation
where they're the same but don't meet
these conditions it would be on a border
so imagine a situation where it's 1 and
1 so it would fall to on or sorry 1 & 0
it right had fall on a border otherwise
it falls to unknown cool
there was another question about
exhaustive checking I'm honestly I don't
know offhand I'd have to look into that
more
does not complain
right I'm not sure so let's catch up
with me afterwards and we'll dig into
more things cool so let's look at ranges
and indices so this is one of the things
that while I was super excited about all
the things that were offered up with
pattern matching because I enjoyed when
they added pattern matching to c-sharp
seven and and furthermore with the point
releases there was a bit of I guess
confusion around ranges specifically and
there's some niceties to them but it's
going to take a bit of time for people
to start writing ranges I think you know
right off the bat I know that I still
look at them and I get confused so
there's some advantages to it but they
they introduced the concept of a hat
operators so we have hats so if we have
a whole bunch of words right the the
quick brown fox jumped over the lazy dog
obviously in any programming language
today we have the notion of arrays so we
have a string array here and at index 0
we have the and index 1 we have quick
and so on and so forth you get the point
but with the hat operator we could say
hat 9 right that is also equivalent to
the in this case because we're starting
at the end of the array and working
backwards so oh look the ID has
suggestions
so let's who's written code like this
before where you try to get like the
last element in an array right so you'll
say words you know brackets words that
length minus 1 so now what the IDE is
suggesting is using indexing can be
simplified right so it's gonna say
instead write it this way where we have
words at 1 which i think is a lot more
expressive and as long as you start
wrapping your head around the concept of
the hat operator of me you know
indicating from the end it's really it's
a nice with you right
so then we can walk up to words and we
can say dot or sorry one dot dot four
and this is a range so we're saying in
this array pick out a range of values
one through four and so we'll end up
with that's exclusively so we'll end up
with the quick brown fox right here we
have what's known as range phrases an
arrange phrase is essentially a literal
so we say hat to dot dot and this is the
last two of something right so this is
how we declare that type and it's an
assignment you'll notice that these are
actually read only structs so I
explicitly typed it here and said range
last two so I could show you how they
kind of broken apart the concept of
ranges and indexes so that range phrase
is equivalent to an instance of a range
which is a read-only struct and the
range type itself has a start and end
index object and that njet index object
is also a read-only struct so we have
the start in the end and those indexes
have is from end bit right a bool that
says whether or not it's from the end
and the corresponding value so that's
how they kind of modeled ranges and
indexes so again we have range phrases
and we can use those we can use those as
literals within again the context of an
array trying to cherry-pick things out
of that as we want we can declare and
assign them as such here and then use
those instances into an index here so we
can say words the last two so then we
Council dot write line string dot join
with an empty space we're just going to
pick out the last two so of the words up
here we have lazy dog all right so we'll
get lazy dog and we'll most plot those
on the screen
so if we wanted everything we can just
say dot dot which I don't know why you
would want to do that you can say dot
dot for right so we can get thee through
fox you can get the last phrase writes
the last phrases six dot dots and get
lazy dog and let's just plot those on
the screen real quick for you to see
so yeah the last word is dog and we
cherry picked out quick brown fox
we had lazy dog right so you kind of get
the point how you can interact with
ranges and indexes and cherry-pick
things out of arrays so I'm curious just
yes or no question do you think that's
useful yeah
show of hands do you think it's
confusing do you think if you had some
really elaborate range phrases that your
friends you know your developer peers
who are doing code reviews would
appreciate that no oh there was a
question in the back here the question
was indexes are zero base and ranges are
one base is that what you said
yeah so there yeah there's there's been
confusion and discussion on Twitter and
on internal emails and stuff like that
uh yes there there's still yeah so from
the end it's it's one based yep
if you yeah if you did it hat zero I
know I don't know if that's valid yeah
come up to me afterwards and we'll play
we'll play around all right
so local functions let's jump into that
real quick so who's used local functions
before who's nested a bunch of local
functions and lost friends don't do that
all right so local functions are pretty
cool when I first saw them I was very
hesitant the idea of having local
functions expressed within a method body
that were defined after a return
statement was concerning to me it looked
weird it didn't feel natural I felt like
this is unreachable code right it's not
going to compile that's local functions
local functions are pretty powerful they
do some pretty amazing things and they
were introduced with c-sharp 7 but now
that we're in c-sharp 8 they're adding a
new concept to them and that's static
locals and it helps with a specific
problem so who's heard of the concept of
implicitly captured variables right
beyond you know enclosure right so in
this scenario we have a classic capture
example where we have a local function
right so we have int I we have a local
function again defined in this case
beneath our return statement so we're
gonna say return Y and our local
function is basically the expression of
y equals 19 because let's keep it very
very simple so when we invoke this we'd
expect it to be Y would be 19 right but
it's doing something very interesting
because the local function is actually
capturing Y kind of beyond the scope
it's inside its own local methods scope
or local function scope and this could
be problematic for reasons so now what
they've introduced is the concept of
static locals so imagine something very
similar where we have an int
y and X you know five and seven and we
want to add those right so return add
X&Y and that's defined statically as int
add left and right and it's simply that
expression left + right but if I was to
come down here and say Y for example
this will actually not compile it's
gonna say the static local function
cannot contain a reference to Y right
and that's a good thing that's a good
developer saying I explicitly do not
want others to come in here and
potentially capture those variables on
intent you know and and mess up the
world basically so that's that static
locals and I think it's a good in
advancement but again going back to the
chip on my shoulder with some of the
features local functions have been one
of those kind of pain points where I've
I've debated whether or not they're good
and they're useful and part of me likes
them part of me is still not a fan of
them I like how they're not nearly as
ugly right so we could write this same
type of function down here as an actual
function and how much uglier would this
be if we said func whoops
not that func give me that yes and give
an int give an int right call it plus
and that equals and a and be expressed
as a yeah we don't need those right so
you get the point who likes writing
stuff like this is this is this better
for anyone who likes being you know
typing out func
another pop quiz is off you know funk of
TTT where those are all ends which
actually is the one that's the return
right versus which are the two
parameters n so I think there's you know
there's some give and take
and I tend to like local functions for
that reason right because they're not as
ugly and it's still it looks very much
like c-sharp without some of the you
know ugliness of funks and actions and
stuff like that alright so we're gonna
talk about using declarations using
declarations or a very interesting one
as a.net developer you're most likely
familiar with AI disposable and the
concept of using statements rights and
how you would have that convenience
functionality within the syntax to say
we're going to use an instance of this
new disposable implementation and
outside of the method you know that that
scope of the execution it'll be disposed
right so under the covers there's a try
finally that's calling dispose on that
instance for you and that's nice but
what we have you know discovered as as
not net developers right it's very
simple to write that and we're used to
it or accustomed to it with c-sharp 8
though they have this notion of
implicitly disposing of things when
they're out of scope so this is how
you'd write it today but with c-sharp 8
imagine writing it like this using var
file equals new stream writer blah blah
blah blah blah and then right you don't
have the brackets and for me I have like
this innate fear where I think to myself
how do I know that this is actually
gonna dispose and it kind of feels icky
right it almost feels like I like I like
being explicit I like saying you know
here's here's my angle brackets my curly
braces and I know that that's going to
work so I'm very torn with this I think
personally with the code that I'll be
reviewing and writing I will not be
using this feature but that's just me
that's my opinion I know that under the
covers it's going to work it's gonna
work the exact same way
I don't know how others
feel about it though is there is there
fear do you would you be fearful of this
does it look like it might open the door
to potential mistakes short hands okay
yeah cool I'm not alone then that's good
to know
awesome so that's yeah that's basically
a walk through most of those let me jump
back in here so we're gonna recap so
just a summary high-level right we saw
the improvements with pattern matching
where we looked at the various new
advancements in how we can express you
know with switch expressions on
individual properties with positional
with tuple literals we can get very very
expressive and I think that's a huge win
I for one love the improvements to
pattern matching I think it's gonna go a
long way it's going to really bolster
the language I'm a big fan of async
streams I think there's definitely use
cases for that if you've been following
along with net core and signal are I've
got a talk tomorrow on signal are so
come check that out but some of the new
primitives that the team's been coming
up with you know channel readers and
writers
some of the they're gonna be able to
start leveraging some of the async
stream methodology which is gonna be
super impactful nullable reference types
another interesting one again I think
the premise behind it is pretty solid
it's gonna start helping developers but
it's going to be a big change so I think
with that feature in particular you can
start doing it in bite-sized chunks if
it's Greenfield obviously start out of
the gate with trying to to incorporate
that right away we looked at the new
range and index types and how those can
be applied and potentially some of the
initial complexity around how you'll
express those and there's already been
debate and chatter in the audience here
as we've talked about that we looked at
the advancements with static local
methods and how we can prevent potential
concerns with consumers
that might fall into the trap of
capturing something implicitly capturing
something they shouldn't we discussed
the implicit dispose and using
declarations right and some of my fears
were expressed very obviously with that
we looked at default interface methods
one thing to note about that
specifically is that this concept of
default interface methods was borrowed
from Java they've been doing it for a
long time and this is probably the only
time I'll mention it during a c-sharp
talk right you don't really usually talk
about Java and then we looked at target
type new expressions which are pretty
cool but also you can kind of do things
potentially even better with some of the
older technologies of c-sharp right with
implicit operators and with that these
are the resources some of the things I
looked at to help build out some of the
demonstration code here there articles
at the top here the first ones what's
new in c-sharp Eights
this is a bitly link for the microsoft
official documentation and then building
c-sharp 8 is kind of more of an insider
view this is a blog from MADD store
Genson who is the lead see sharp
designer out Microsoft and with that
thank you so much for having me it's my
first NDC talk super excited to be here
thank you so much for listening
[Applause]